we start tonight an important monologue
on the mainstream media here is what I
want to explain to you hating President
Trump is their drug in the media and by
the way to them it's more addictive than
heroin and crack cocaine let me explain
because in the liberal media bubble a
trump tweet literally sends them into
orbit alka-seltzer in water they bubble
and fizz every day and it's like a
dopamine rush to their brains the drug
is that powerful they can't duplicate it
any other way
let me tell you how it works President
Trump usually tweets to get around the
media and their twisted distorted fake
news coverage and rightly so goes
directly to you the American people and
a lot of times with humor they can't
recognize and the media then promptly
proceeds they've rushed to the Airways
and they try and outdo each other
feigning more outrage than the other one
here's the latest example watch just
watch how the media reacted to president
Trump's recent tweets you can't make
this up sixteen tweets today to start
the new year
some of them deeply disturbed but these
are the messages from a person who is
not well from a leader who is not fit
for office this is a language that would
have been rejected from the script of
dr. Strangelove
we can't begin to normalize this this is
dangerous this is childish this is
unpresidential it's not befitting the
leader of the free world
none of this normal none of this
acceptable none of this frankly stable
behavior this is so far outside the
principles and and and the norms of
presidential behavior that we are in an
outerspace realm here this is what
happens in authoritarian countries
companies be medicated and hospitalized
so he is going to just kill all of us
he is not merely being cavalier with a
threat about nuclear war he's being
cavalier in a way that it makes him seem
demented and deranged perhaps never have
we seen a man whose profound sexual and
masculine insecurities are literally
threatening to annihilate the planet
really president Trump is demented let's
see because he's responding to a nuclear
threat from North Korea now not only are
they all a bunch of sheep you notice
they all say pretty much the same thing
but they're drug addicts in this sense
they crave their next Trump tweet they
need their fix and for some reason
there's not a tweet within 24 hours
there's not a comment there's no fake
outrage well then they have to latch on
to something that'll satisfy their
craving they just race back to their
gateway drug Oh
Trump Russia Trump Russia but with the
Trump Russia collusion story now falling
flat that's kind of like the equivalent
of methadone it's only a maintenance
drug that barely separates them from
like a padded room and a some Asylum
somewhere and for over a year
you have been subjected to Russia Russia
Russia collusion collusion collusion
only thing missing are facts facts facts
and the media desperately repeating
those words daily hoping that somehow if
they say it enough it's gonna come true
here's the problem it's not true
there is to date zero evidence president
Trump colluded with Russia none
whatsoever
it doesn't exist so the media now they
need a new conspiracy theory that they
can pass off as news to get themselves
well back on their drug get hooked again
and it's actually in one sense it's sad
because these people really need help
they have no let's say they don't want
to adhere to truth anymore that's a sad
thing now if you think about it for a
second does the media ever when you
watch the news did they ever talk about
anything Donald Trump that he did is
good any good news any good news with
the economy or they just obsessed with
tearing this president down because they
never thought he'd win do they ever talk
about the American people solutions for
health care
getting people out of poverty off of
food stamps back to work I never hear it
if the media really cared about anything
of real importance then guess what
they'd have to alter their constructed
worship you know sites of Obama during
his failed presidency and by the way
they would have in those years seeing
the millions of more Americans in
poverty and on food stamps they would
have stood up for you but liking Obama
was more important now president Trump's
tweets about North Korea let's get into
this they are perfect examples what did
the president say that is so dangerous
that you see them unleash like they did
in the last 24 hours
let's see he stood up to a two-bit
murdering dictator and he called them
little rocket man and he said that the
United States is not going to be
intimidated by his little red button on
his desk and for the media that kind of
leadership well they don't like it it's
not good enough since what they're used
to and what they personally support are
the policies of appeasement so we have
to ask is there anything the president
Trump could do to make the media ever
happy in this situation with Kim jong-un
by the way a situation Bill Clinton put
us in now the press probably wants
presidents from maybe they'd be happy if
he got down on his knees and kissed Kim
jong-un's ring on his little hand then
they'd be calling for him to get the
Nobel Prize or maybe the media would be
happy if Trump gave billions of dollars
in fuel subsidies to North Korea like
Bill Clinton did or maybe Trump should
suck up and grovel to Kim jong-un just
like Bill Clinton sucked up and grovel
to Kim jong-il his father then Trump
could go on TV like Bill Clinton didn't
tell you the American people a massive
lie like this this is a good deal for
the United States North Korea will
freeze and then dismantle its nuclear
program South Korea and our other allies
will be better protected the entire
world will be safer as we slow the
spread of nuclear weapons South Korea
with support from Japan and other
patience will bear most of the cost of
providing North Korea with fuel to make
up for the nuclear energy it is losing
and they will pay for an alternative
power system for North Korea that will
allow them to produce electricity while
making it much harder for them to
produce nuclear weapons the United
States and international inspectors will
carefully monitor North Korea to make
sure it keeps its commitments only as it
does so will North Korea fully join the
community of nations could Bill Clinton
have been more wrong
or how about this one maybe the media
maybe they'd be ecstatic really really
happy if President Trump sucked up to
the Iranian mullahs maybe if President
Trump sent them another hundred and
fifty billion dollars like Obama did and
begged on his hands and knees pretty
pretty pretty please here's billions of
dollars just please stop saying you're
gonna wipe us off the face of the earth
please stop saying you'll destroy Israel
please stop burning our flags that's
what they want in the press that's
pathetic it's weak and they're not doing
a service to you the American people
I've said this many times they are lazy
and they are overpaid and they are a
bunch of sycophants that alt retweet
each other in their little media bubble
the sky is literally you know falling
down for these people all because Donald
Trump dared to stand up and challenge a
murdering dictator the media lives in
this bubble these people are stepping
all over themselves they want to all
outdo each other it's like a competition
you know let's see who can be the most
anti Trump and if one liberal media
personality said president Trump is
demented then another has to step in and
say no he's really really demented and
he's really really a big big big big big
big liar and it goes on from there see
what I mean by drug addiction it's it's
like in part it's like initiation into
their hate Trump Club and to be a member
you just have to hate everything and
it's happening every single hour of
every single day on every single news
channel and in the mainstream media
non-stop that's all they do
that's their go to and that is what now
the media in this country has become and
it's why I've been telling you since
2007 and eight journalism in America is
dead
it's done these so-called journalists
they don't care about truth anymore
facts be damned evidence be damned
because if they did care about truth
then they'd actually start doing their
jobs because we know of crimes committed
they'd be investigating massive scandals
that are staring them right in the face
they could win their Pulitzer Prizes
they're dreaming about none of what
we're about to tell you is important to
the media but it all should be they're
not doing their job it's about the
system of justice in America it's now
hanging in the ballast balance equal
application under the law the media
ignores this why because they need their
Trump hate addiction fix you know an
explosive report the hills John Solomon
revealing that written FBI documents
show agents working on the Clinton email
investigation all believed lost were
broken in addition 17 witnesses
interviewed after James Comey already
drafted the exoneration statement of
Hillary the fix was in it was rigged
it was exoneration before investigation
we have even more proof does the media
even care about it or are they spreading
their Trump Russia conspiracy theory is
that more important after a year of no
facts and a year of anonymous sources
how about you know Trump hating and
Clinton loving FBI agent Peter struck
and his FBI lawyer girlfriend Lisa Paige
completely trashing President Trump on
text messages they called him a lonesome
human being an idiot and struck and
Paige also talked about an insurance
policy in Andy's office which we believe
is the deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
in case Donald Trump won the election
and remember it was struck and call me
they are the ones that change the the
verbage in the exoneration letter before
the investigation was done none of this
is important to the media it should be
there's special counsel Robert Muller
his merrie team of democratic generous
donors they don't donate to Republicans
50 grand to Democrats including Hillary
and Barack Obama and of course none of
them gave to president Trump's campaign
one of Muller's lead investigators
jeanne ray actually represented Clinton
and the Clinton Foundation in 2015 you
can't get a bigger conflict of interest
nothing from the media and we have
Muller's top prosecutor the expert
Andrew Weitzman the professional he is
he led the extremely controversial
obstruction of justice case against
Arthur Andersen accounting as part of
the Enron scandal he destroyed that
company cost tens of thousands of people
their jobs and was overturned in the US
Supreme Court and oh five nine zero
yeah that's a great guy to put on your
team and then he also sent for Merrill
Lynch executives to jail their
convictions were also overturned that
case by the fifth US Circuit Court of
Appeals does the media not care about
any of this if it was a bunch of
Republican donators donors and and
giving donations to Trump investigating
Hillary Clinton don't you think it would
be the biggest story ever really now
next of course you have the demoted DOJ
official Bruce or his wife Nellie Bruce
or meets with members of fusion GPS
before and after the 2016 election and
Nellie his wife Nellie or worked for the
firm that Hillary Clinton and the DNC
paid to produce the fake phony
propaganda Russian anti Trump dossier
and then finally the FBI deputy director
Andrew McCabe his wife Jill gets 700
grand from a longtime Clinton ally
remember former Virginia Governor Terry
McAuliffe Democrats all that money given
for a failed Virginia state Senate run
that is an astronomical sum in a Senate
race in Virginia these are all
individually massive stories not even
mentioning uranium one about let's see
bribery extortion money laundering
kickbacks and they knew it before
cepheus before nine separate agencies
approved of giving 20% of our uranium
knowing that Vladimir Putin's thugs were
in America trying to get a foothold into
the uranium industry in our country we
don't have enough we need more it's
insane then you look at the money behind
that you have mountains of evidence here
of wrongdoing the media is not touching
any of it why because the media is
infatuated they cannot control
themselves anymore and it's all about
hating President Trump it's kind of like
a sickness doesn't have a cure
apparently never will they can't see
anything else that is their singular
focus
even by the way they would prefer
kissing the rings and backsides of
dictators the media is betraying you the
American people now you would think the
press you think they'd have some sort of
ethical compass something that would
move them towards truth but they're now
so corrupted morally bankrupt they hate
any and everybody that doesn't do it
their way the media tonight they're
hyperventilating again foaming at the
mouth the back-and-forth between
presidents from former White House
adviser Steve banning president Trump
responding to comments Bannon apparently
made and is soon to be released book by
Michael Wolfe here's the thing the media
loves love Steve man and for the moment
they love when Republicans or
conservatives are fighting and create a
circular firing squad in real life they
hate Bannon and they hate Trump and but
they'll you know right now they'll be
supportive of Steve Bannon if he think
he's advancing there call us they love
these intramural fights they love palace
intrigue
they love to analyze who's up who's down
it's another example the media's
priorities are so screwed up when do
they ever talk about you when do they
ever talk about making your life better
your kids lives better here's another
thing that I've said before anyone who
works in the White House they're there
to serve the country and the president
that's it and the American people and
that should be the main goal people
asking me all day today what do you
think about you know this i think this i
think the agenda of the American people
is point one two three four and a
thousand and that should be the focus of
everybody this isn't going to be a story
in 48 hours instead of blowing this out
of proportion like the media always does
maybe they should be focused on this
look at this painting by John McNaughton
guy this out in Utah great guy great
painter
I bought that original painting see that
guy sitting on the bench he represents
that's called the forgotten man painting
that represents the forgotten men and
women in this country all those people
in poverty all those people in food
stamps all those people that don't have
jobs we should be focused on creating
jobs energy independence securing our
borders fighting back again
radical islamists rebuilding the
military that's where my focus is